speaking of destroying the enemy next
question is how do you deal with rules
of engagement
are they necessary did they inhibit you
this is a question we get all the time
and people want to talk about rules of
engagement
you know everyone there's always
complaints guys you come back from the
battlefield like the rules of engagement
are so stringent
and these are different wars we're
fighting these are counter insurgency
wars
and oftentimes people use the term
civilian casualties
uh in a way that that's you know they're
talking about
innocent civilians but what they don't
realize
is that everyone we're fighting is a
civilian none of them are
uniformed members of an opposing
military they blend into the populace
they act like they're normal people they
hide amongst
the people off sometimes use them as
human shields
and then they're shooting at you and
shooting rpgs or or
machine guns at you and they maneuver so
it's a very challenging environment
but the rules of engagement really don't
change their rules of engagement are
pretty clear
and uh they're you observe a hostile act
bad guys shooting at you or shooting at
friendlies or a hot you
you observe hostile intent meaning that
and that's where it becomes a little
more gray area to say
okay was this was that person acting in
a manner
that had a reasonable certainty of
hostile intent and so uh
it's it's a judgment call up to uh
up to the troops on the battlefield and
those rules of engagement don't change
they're always the same i think what
changes is elite
is leaders leaders change and there's
some leaders that are willing to
delegate that down to the lowest level
troopers
trust in their guys train them make it
make them understand
just how important it is to make sure uh
you know that that uh that they're
operating within that rules of
engagement that they are
you know not uh accidentally engaging
some innocent person and causing
you know collateral damage that they
didn't mean to so uh and there are some
leaders that
won't delegate that and keep it tight
and and want to really scrutinize guys
for making the call
i think the best way uh for us this was
incredibly important people didn't
understand how you know
our troops are put in a tough position
because
we know that anything we do in today's
world with social media with news
you know news cycles could be absolute
front page headline news
uh in a heartbeat and uh and those can
have
massive catastrophic effect on
on the entire you know strategy yeah the
strategic
uh mission so this is uh this is
something that we have to deal with
regularly
and uh and if a guy thought
you know he thought he saw someone
digging in the road and there were an
ied layer and
and he decided to pull the trigger on
someone he thought was an id layer and
it turns out it's not
we get investigated for that we it
becomes a big deal and and
that shooter our u.s servicemen who
or or woman who engaged uh
is potentially looking at going to
prison
for uh you know for something like that
so it's a big deal if they violated the
rules of engagement
one of the ways that uh jocko did an
amazing job of this and and you know one
of our four principles
our laws of combat that we talk about is
simple
and one of the ways that he did this for
us
was you know all this lawyer speak of
high
reasonable certainty of hostile intent
and all these things he would stand up
before we rolled out the gate
every time every single operation and
say
if you have to pull the trigger you
better make sure
the guy you're killing is bad simple
everyone understood that and it we had
total faith and trust in our guys to do
that and i'm so proud of that
that they were able to execute with
tremendous discipline
and and minimize collateral damage in in
a way that other units couldn't you know
in
the way we did that so um i think uh
rules of engagement
are necessary people have to understand
them and it's really
whether or not uh you it's delegated
down is entirely
up to a leader yeah and you could see
the uh
the the situation that led up to milai
which we did a couple podcasts ago
that the rules of engagement were the
way that they were briefed it wasn't
hey make sure the people that you're
killing are bad it was
everyone in this area is hostile
everyone has been warned
if they're that to leave so everyone you
see
is either viet cong or viet cong
sympathizer
killed them and there's some scrutiny
about whether they said kill them or not
because that because that was a pretty
simple clear message
but you know the difference in that
the way that the rules of engagement
were briefed were
definitely a a
a a cause one of the causes for the me
lie massacre happening
it's it's a awful situation
rules of engagement